[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez publié votre père
récemment il a appelé neige et pas
répondu vous avez posé des limites je
vois vous avez un chaton dans votre sac
et ça y est vous devez le cliché ça doit
faire une heure là non tout décide en
fait un bras pleins d'effets [ __ ] à la
porte c'est ça la présence d'hommes
dotée d'une aussi piètre intégrité
morale n'est pas souhaitable pour les
bergers quelques jours la dernière fois
que papa est venu à la maison le fbi
elle m'a filé jusqu'au boulot pendant
une semaine je le prendrais chez moi
mais son style de vie est un très
mauvais exemple pour henry se veut dire
qu'on basware à leur nom âge est nommé
dans un avis
je ne conduirai patron tas de ferraille
mais j'aimerais aussi passer un peu de
temps avec ma famille c'est absolument
hors de question
il ya dans ce coffre pour 200 mille
dollars double tout est là j'arriverai
pas à écouler le stock tout ça tu peux
compter sur moi c'est toi qui as changer
l'itinéraire
il m'a donné 20 $ henry estime un ami de
ton grand père refuse dinaly quoi que ce
soit ou non ça suffit j'ai regagné plus
de ciel comme le joueur de flûte de
hamelin
pourquoi tu râles à ce point tu parles
de jack moi je l'aï bien là ce pont 6,38
moi je vais bien mais lui c'est pas
pareil
destiné à quelqu'un que ta mère n'a pas
trop au pouvoir qui sait qu'on perd
j'aimerais le voir je suis très heureux
j'ai choisi le pire des marques et
histoire j'aurais pas de nous dire
annoncé dimanche misty étanche en vue
que je te dise que mustier mon chat
c'est qui mon chat j'ai fixé une limite
bonjour j'ai construit une paresse elle
est en béton armé bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la famille c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
important on rigolait bien tous les deux
alors j'hérite mois
je croyais que des bouddhistes lui mais
tu as réussi à exacerber mon côté obscur
d'anciens chrétiens
[Musique]